president biden on friday shared new
details about his phone conversations
with israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu as he worked to arrange a
ceasefire between israel and the islamic
militant groups
group hamas mr biden also promised
visiting south korean president
moon jae-in that the u.s would provide
much-needed vaccines
for more than a half-million south
korean troops deborah alferon has more
from the white house deborah good
morning
good morning dana south korean president
moon jae-in is the second foreign leader
that biden has hosted here
at the white house and the two heads of
state agree
they want complete denuclearization in
the korean peninsula
biden did name an envoy to the region
but with everything going on in the
middle east
and this cease-fire stretching into the
weekend that
threatened to take center stage
a day after a cease-fire was declared
between israel and hamas
president biden said israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
promised him he would not break it i'm
praying this ceasefire will hold
i take bibi netanyahu when he gives me
his word
i take him at his word he's never broken
his word to me
mr biden whose relationship with mr
netanyahu has been tense in the past
spoke with the israeli leader six times
during the conflict
to help negotiate a ceasefire what i've
made clear
is that it's essential it's essential
that
the palestinians in on the west bank
be secured that abbas
be recognized as the leader of the
palestinian people which he is hamas
is a terrorist organization we've
recognized that that doesn't mean we
should not be in gaza
rebuilding gaza for all those innocent
people who in fact
have been hurt and and have been
collateral damage
including loss of homes and a whole
range of other things our cooperation is
vital
to maintaining peace and stability
earlier the president and the south
korean leader both
shared their deep concern with the
situation with north korea
mr biden said a meeting with kim jong-un
is
not off the table and took a jab at his
predecessor
who met twice with the north korean
leader without any commitments on their
nuclear arsenal
what i would not do is i would not do
what had been done in the recent past i
would
not give him all that he's looking for
his
national international recognition as
legitimist i would make sure that
my team had met with his counterparts
and i knew exactly what we're meeting
now
and one other thing that made news
yesterday president biden vowed that his
administration would never
seize the phone records of journalists
that's something
that the trump administration's
department of justice had reportedly
done in the past
he said it would never happen and that
it was wrong michelle
all right deborah thank you so much